[Music]
margot robbie plain Tonya Harding on
screen is everything and these exclusive
new scenes from I Tanya
everyone has their own truth
Marco channels the disgraced Olympic
skater in her 1990s bedazzled costumes I
was the best picture skater in the world
at one point in time
Marco trained five days a week because
she couldn't figure skate at all
everyone's like what you don't know how
to skate and I was like I grew up on the
Gold Coast rally I know I don't know how
to ice skate we didn't do that her
domineering mom is played by Allison
Janney and I was a kid did you ever love
me I made you a champion it really
wasn't as big a physical transformation
as one might assume for the aging make
up wheat that was weight gain and stuff
like that so prosthetics involved those
prosthetics include a fake nose and
padding to make her appear heavier we
also judge on presentation and we get to
see that infamous attack on her rival
Nancy Kerrigan come on
what kind of friggin person bashes in
their friend's knee who would do that to
a friend now just so you know the real
Tanya supports Margo doing this she even
texted Margo before the film's premiere
in Toronto
[Music]